en temps habituel c'est l'effervescence
dans les centres de formation et
établissements supérieurs avec les
portes ouvertes pour recruter les futurs
étudiants des portes ouvertes virtuelle
cette année comme un institut de
formation des professions de santé
le secteur de la santé à la fois ultra
sollicité pendant cette crise sanitaire
est en souffrance
les postes sont là en nombre qu'en est
il des candidats et quelle est la
motivation des étudiants
audrey champigny ils sont nos
ambulanciers noz aides soignants et nos
infirmiers de demain ici à l'institut de
formation des professions de santé à
deux pas du chu trousseau
on apprend à faire des piqûres lire une
radio un tube est impatient ou encore
préparer des médicaments
yannick le gall elle est formatrice
anesthésistes ce qu'on apprend aux
infirmiers anesthésistes basse et à
travailler en binôme avec un médecin
anesthésiste pour endormir et réveiller
les patients qui passent au bloc
opératoire pour une intervention
chirurgicale via les qualités c'est
surtout savoir gérer son stress
et puis savoir s'adapter avec la crise
beaucoup ont été sollicités pour prêter
main forte
une mise en pratique un peu accéléré
mais salutaire en 2e année nous on a été
assez infecté parce que
du coup l'année dernière donc en
première année on a eu un stage en moins
on nous a demandé c'est vrai de nous
investir et ce qu'on a tous trouvé je
pense dans la promotion normal donc ça
nous a aussi permis de découvrir le côté
aides soignants pour ceux qui voulaient
travailler de découvrir une autre
facette du métier et c'est vrai qu'on
découvre aussi un côté un petit peu plus
speed on va dire parmi les 1200
étudiants de l'unef ps une majorité
d'élèves infirmiers 184 par promo une
vocation qui attire toujours plus depuis
deux trois ans de toute façon on n'avait
jusqu'en 2017 2018 sur les concours un
peu une baisse de candidats et depuis
parcours su qu'au contraire on a eu un
nouveau une aspiration et on l'a vu même
chez nos propres étudiants qui ont
témoigné durant la crise sanitaire voilà
de l'engouement pour cette profession
qui souhaitent exercer et ils sont rendu
compte en faisant leur stage durant la
crise ô combien il se sentait utile
importants pour le système de santé pour
la prise en soin de la population ali
fps ne filières sont proposées des
formations plus ou moins longue de 4
mois pour les ambulanciers à trois ans
pour les infirmiers
nous avons un quota de candidats qui
vont relever de parcours sup ce sont les
néo bachelier entre autres et dans ce
quota il ya 25% qui est tourné vers des
personnes en reconversion
professionnelle
et c'est particulièrement important de
le signaler aujourd'hui parce que
souvent c'est oublier autre voie qui est
en train de se développer
l'apprentissage dans le système de santé
en effet les besoins côté employeurs
sont de plus en plus nombreux